is lending his voice to something other
than singing and no we're not talking
about him starting a podcast our
canadian boy is taking a stab at voice
acting by playing the lead role of lyle
the crocodile in the upcoming film lyle
crocodile which is based on the popular
children's book by bernard weber now the
movie sees a house dwelling crocodile
owned by javier bardem's character
hector befriend his next door neighbor
despite her mother's wishes
mom i swear to you he's not dangerous
he's a crocodile okay yes crocodiles can
bite through bonin yes they have a taste
for human flesh but he's not like that
he wears a scarf
of course sean took to his socials to
express his excitement for the upcoming
film writing this so proud to be part of
lyle crocodile i've always been in awe
of the work that songwriters pasik and
paul do and it was also a dream working
with the entire lyell team javier
constance and the entire cast are
magical i can't wait for you all to see
this film but that's not all for the
singer lyle isle crocodile will also
include a brand new track by sean
written by the same musical team who
brought the greatest showman to life the
trailer gave us a little snippet of what
sure to be a brand new sean mendes
[Music]
one
hit